على كل حال من السعوديه سالنا السيدات هل
علامات التجميل مشاهير تؤثر على قراراتك
الشرائيه للمنتجات نتابع الاجابات
حتى لو كانت تاثر فانا اعتبرها تاثر بشكل
ايجابي انه يعني ما عدا التخلي للامانه او
انا اتكلم عن نفسي شخصيا ما تهمني
البراندات ولا تهمني قديش انا ادفع ان انا
ما اتخيل نفسي ممكن احط عشرين الف شنطه
بين ممكن العشرين الف تكلفني سفره انا
انبسط فيها ممكن تؤثر عليه اذا كان الشيء
اللي عرضاه يناسبني ويناسب احتياجاتي عادي
اشتريه واذا شيء ما يناسبني ما حاشتغل
اكيد لا لانه كلها بتكون اعلان ودعايات هم
الكسبانين فيها لكن المتضررين احنا فيها
لانه بس موضوع انه شهره لهم تمام وياخذوا
عليها مكاسب واحنا اللي قليل العقل هو
اللي بيشتري يمشي معاهم زمان كانت تؤثر
علي بس لما شفت ان المصداقيه ما هي عاليه
عند المشاهير ياثر فيا صارت عن تجربه
شخصيه ما بيهمني المشاهير بيهمني البراند
تكون هي عجبتني او حتى من لوكال ديزاين ما
بتفرق معي صراحه طبعا بالنسبه لمستحضرات
التجميل
[موسيقى]